it is top five time which means i've got
the very best of this week's gaming news
so let's get you all the way from ryze
son of rome to halo in the next three or
so minutes
first off rice on a room for pc has
dropped the xbox one's micro
transactions developer crytek laid out a
bunch of features in the pc version
including 4k res support native
upscaling and the ability to select the
resolution you want ryze rendered at
there's a whole bunch of graphical
options you'll be able to mess with and
the pc version contains the four dlc
expansion packs that were released for
the xbox one game crytek added we have
also removed the optional micro
transactions that were present on xbox
one
blizzard spent seven years developing
next-gen mmo titan and this week they
made the call to cancel it president of
blizzard mike mohamed told polygon that
the game just wasn't working out and
that they couldn't find the fun or the
passion to justify continued development
blizzard said deciding to drop the
project was a huge and difficult
decision but that the discipline of
knowing when to quit is important
upcoming action rpg laws of the fallen
is set to be 1080p on ps4 and 900p on
xbox one creative director thomas goff
confirmed to video gamer that despite
the resolution difference the xbox one
and ps4 versions are pretty much similar
cop said a resolution boost for the xbox
one between now and the launch of lords
of the fallen on october 28 is unlikely
he explains pretty much the only thing
that we're doing is last minute fixes
but we've already been certified
the evil within pc system specs have
been revealed as have the console
install sizes bethesda haven't released
bare minimum specs but you can find all
the recommended bits and pieces on site
which include 4 gigabytes of ram and 50
gigabytes of hard drive space if you're
after the xbox one or ps4 versions
you'll need 40 gig of space on your
console of choice check out the specs on
gamespot and let me know if your pc is
up to scratch
finally microsoft have explained why pc
gamers won't be able to play halo the
master chief collection on their
platform of choice microsoft have said
that while a pc version isn't totally
ruled out it's not on the cards right
now explaining that they wanted to do a
great job on console that aside 343
industries executive producer dan ayoob
said that the appeal of the massive pc
market isn't lost on them for the moment
though the master chief collection is
intended to be an incentive to pick
yourself up in xbox one if you haven't
yet
let me know down in the comments what
you cared about this week and if you've
been eyeing off the master chief
collection as for what's on site this
week check out my just episode on game
delays skyrim mods adopts a pet robot
dog and we've got 20 minutes of
borderlands the pre-sequel that is it
from me this week thanks for sticking
around as always and i will catch you
again on monday
you